an open Total mesorectal excision or TM
is a surgical procedure to remove your
rectum and some of the tissue around
it your rectum is the last part of your
large intestine before the anal
Canal the rectum stores Solid Waste
called feces until you pass it out of
your
body the mesor rectum is the tissue
around your rectum that contains lymph
nodes a total mesorectal excision is
performed to treat cancer in your rectum
as well as cancer that may have spread
to the lymph nodes around your
rectum an open Total mesor rectal
excision will begin with an incision in
your
abdomen inside your abdomen your surgeon
will separate the large intestine above
your rectum from the tissue covering
it then your rectum and mesor rectum
will be separated from the tissue in
your
pelvis your large intestine will be
divided above your rectum and closed
with staples or sutures your rectum will
be divided above your anal canal and
removed next your surgeon will create a
pouch at the end of your colon the pouch
will function like a rectum because it
will store
feces this pouch will be attached to
your anal
canal
at the end of the procedure the incision
in your abdomen will be closed with
staples or
stitches at this point your surgeon will
sometimes create a different way for
feces to leave your body while the new
attachment heals to do this your surgeon
will make a separate incision in your
abdomen and pull a loop of your small
intestine through
it the loop will be opened and attached
to the incision the opening is called a
sto a bag will be attached to the stoma
to allow feces to drain into
it later when your large intestine has
healed you will have another procedure
to close the
stom this will allow feces to pass out
of your body the usual
way if you have questions about rectal
removal surgery talk to your healthare
provider
I